mr. Kelly mr. Kelly on at least one
occasion told associate number one that
he would be quote dead close quotes if
another copy of the first tape surfaced
mr. kelly also bragged to associate
number one that he had dotted his eyes
and crossed his T's quote unquote and
that the young girl who was depicted in
the videos and the young girl's family
would not testify against him in
connection with the trial because he had
relocated them and paid them off it was
subsequently learned that mr. Kelly
through multiple means had paid the
young victim and her family over two
million dollars not to testify and come
forward in connection with the 2008
trial so to those our Kelly fans who
want to talk about the 2008 trial and
the fact that he was acquitted it was
bogus our Kelly bought his acquittal he
bought this victim and their parents and
ensured that the truth was never told to
that jury in 2008 there were subsequent
disputes between mr. Kelly and associate
number one relating to the payment of
the monies for the recovery of the first
tape those were documented
contemporaneous leave meaning there are
contemporaneous documents from that time
period making it impossible for this to
have only now been fabricated
on one occasion mr. Kelly and mr.
McDavid paid associate number one
approximately a hundred and sixty to one
hundred and seventy thousand dollars in
cash contained inside a shopping bag
this was during the 2008 trial and it
was done to ensure that associate number
one did not come forward and describe
the obstruction of justice that had been
carried out at the request of mr. Kelly
ultimately a copy of that first
videotape was provided to miss Fox's
office by me in February of 2019 earlier
this year there is no question relating
to the chain of custody of that
videotape what it represents whether our
Kelly is on it whether he paid a
significant sum of money together with
others in order to attempt to bury it
and prevent the truth from coming out be
clear our Kelly and those around him
obstructed justice in connection with
the 2008 trial those are some of the
charges that he now faces and I am
highly confident that when all the
evidence is heard that he will be
convicted along with others around him
of obstructing justice in connection
with the 2008 tribe
we have now provided two video tapes to
law enforcement we are presently trying
to locate a third videotape that we know
exists that is the tape with Miss Van
Alen mr. Kelly and the 14 year old girl
the reports of 20 video tapes being
provided to law enforcement are
completely bogus ridiculous absurd
nonsensical I don't know what other
words I can use whoever is reporting
that should be ashamed of themselves
because whatever source they're using is
ridiculous bogus not credible ladies and
gentlemen it has been half 20 video
tapes have not been turned over to law
enforcement what else is bogus and
ridiculous this story that recently was
reported about the two young ladies Miss
Savage and Miss Clary being evicted from
the Trump Tower
whoever reported that you should be
ashamed of yourself you're not a
journalist it's disgraceful it's
operating about cliques and do your job
those young ladies have not been
depicted they may or be have not been
evicted they may be evicted within 30
days but they presently have not been
evicted why do I care about this why do
I care whether this false information
about 20 videotapes etc is out there
I'll tell you exactly why I care this is
a serious matter and I want to ensure
that justice is done here the media has
a responsibility to get it right there's
a lot of people out there that are
trying to plant bogus stories only so
they could be knocked down what do we
see earlier today we saw the eviction
story being knocked down by the two
young ladies they posted a video of them
sitting in the Trump Tower am I
surprised by that no because I knew it
was false before the press reports on
facts relating to this you need to ask
questions is
where this information is coming from
and whether the individuals have any
basis to actually know about a major
national network contacted me on
Saturday or Sunday and asked me if both
miss Savage and Miss Clary were in
Atlanta
they had received a report that they
were in Atlanta and they were getting
ready to run the story
I represent Alice and Angelo Clary I
still represent them they are in touch
with their daughter she is here in
Chicago she never went to Atlanta miss
savage also has not gone to Atlanta once
again I don't know where this
information is coming from it's not
accurate as it relates to Alice and
Angelo Clary like I said they are in
contact with their daughter they are in
the process of trying to be reunited
with their daughter they hope to be
reunited with their daughter shortly
obviously this has been a very long road
for both their daughter and them and you
can only imagine the amount of time that
it's going to take for that relationship
to be repaired I want to address one
more issue before I take questions the
people that on social be the people on
social media and others that are talking
about the fact that this is somehow
driven by racism or bigotry should be
ashamed of themselves every one of my
clients is African American this doesn't
have anything to do with race this has
everything to do with justice and what's
right and wrong
many of the investigators are African
American this is a case about young
girls many of whom came from rough
neighborhoods who were economically
disadvantaged and were easily preyed
upon by a guy who used his power
and wealth and contacts to get away with
it for almost thirty years that's what
this case is about it's not about black
and white it's about right and wrong so
I'll be happy to take some questions we
have turned over two tapes both tapes to
pick mr. Kelly with a girl who is 14
years of age same girl clearly depict
mr. Kelly there's no question that it's
him the mole is clearly visible on his
back they both the young girl and mr.
Kelly reference the fact that she's 14
on both of these tapes there's a third
tape that we are trying to locate that
tape
we understand depicts mr. Kelly with the
same 14 year old girl together with Miss
Lisa Van Alen we we initially provided
the tapes to Cook County and they in
turn provided them to federal law
enforcement well the tape
I think the tapes would be used as
evidence in all of the cases both in the
state case as well in both federal cases
well I certainly think that there's
substantial evidence of that in light of
how long this occurred where it occurred
the number of states that were involved
this was not some isolated incident I
mean you are talking about literally
dozens of victims well the progress is
incremental again as you can imagine
this is a very emotional time I think
that miss Clary and Miss Savage likely
will slowly come to the realization that
this is over and when I say it's over
I'd be very very surprised if mr. Kelly
ever sees the light of day again outside
of federal custody at this point in his
life I do not think he would be granted
bail in connection with both of these
proceedings and I believe that
ultimately he will serve a lengthy and
rightful prison sentence for his decades
of abuse I think it's going to take time
for both of them to come to that
realization you know these two young
ladies have been brainwashed for the
better part of two three four years in
many instances they've been fed quite a
story by mr. Kelly and from what I've
heard and the evidence that I've seen
this man is a sociopath
in every in every term in every way
every sense of the word the conduct that
this man engaged in had he not been as
successful as a songwriter and performer
he would have been locked up for the
rest of his life a long time ago
text messages actual phone calls they've
had text messages and telephonic
communications I don't want to get into
the details of what they discuss because
again I don't want to violate their
privacy but this is going to be an
incremental and slow process and and I'm
hopeful and they're hopeful that they're
going to be able to rebuild the
relationship with their daughter who
they love very much I believe yesterday
there's a number of unidentified victims
and there's a number of other identified
victims who have not been cooperative
thus far with law enforcement and have
not been willing to provide interviews
or statements to law enforcement and I
believe that the hope is that as time
progresses and as people began to
realize that again this is over that
they will come forward and do the right
thing and also have the courage to
disclose what happened to them